nicer is for inviting me I'm going to
talk about locally testable codes and l1
embeddings of kaylee graphs and
naturally I'll start by defining what
all these objects are so you know this
is day for the workshop I don't need to
define a local tester but I'm going to
do it anyway we're going to be talking
about local testers for binary linear
codes right so if i have an nkd linear
code a local tester for it is basically
a very efficient algorithm which decides
membership in the code we wanted to read
very few coordinates in the code except
something which is of code word and
reject things which are sufficiently far
away now a very nice early result in
this area due to benzoyl and Harsha and
rajkot Nicola says that the natural
testers you can think of or as general
as you could hope for they say that a
local tester is essentially a
distribution on low weight dual code
words so dual code words are basically
the equations that code that things in
the code should satisfy their saying
that what your tester should do is come
up with some nights distribution on
these dual code words and then just
sample from the distribution check if
the received word satisfies this
equation if it does then except
otherwise reject right such a test is
obviously going to accept good words the
question is whether it's going to reject
things Joe far away so formally I should
mention that this notion of locally
testable code has a long history going
back to work on PC peas and program
checking and so on it was defined in
these works of Blum Looby rubenfeld to
bedford sudan and fiddled Susan formerly
a tester for an NK D linear code it
queries coordinates according to some
distribution be on dual code words now
usually the definition of local tester
requires that you don't read too many
coordinates which is that the weight of
the dual code word is small I'm going to
work with a slightly different
definition which is essentially
equivalent so for the purposes of the
stock let's just assume that these two
definitions are the same I'm going to
require my tester to be epsilon smooth
where epsilon smooth means that you
query any coordinate in the code with
probability
most Epsilon so how do you match this
notion up with the standard notion of a
tester which reads few coordinates well
if you are reading only q coordinates
where q is some constant then that
corresponds to the smoothness parameter
being something like oh of 1 over n
where n is the length of the code right
so while I doing this this way well you
see in a while right so now okay so now
we have a tester which is smooth what is
the soundness requirement well because
you're reading just each coordinate only
with probability epsilon if something is
at distance one from the code you only
got a dejected probability Epsilon but
what you'd like is that as things get
further and further from the code the
probability of rejection goes up ideally
by the time the distance is something
like d over for you want this
probability to be an absolute constant
and you could just say that this is your
soundness requirement or more
ambitiously you could require that
actually as things get further away the
probability of rejection increases
linearly with distance from the course I
see these the minus distance D is the
minimum distance of the code yeah so the
equivalent sort of means that is in the
dual code we have no low weight no low
weight elements then you cannot explain
then already this earlier result which
we talked about says that such codes are
not locally testable so even this you
have to have a distribution on low rate
code words so that it's smooth but
otherwise the code is just not testable
ok so my notion of this of soundness is
going to be the following that if
something is a distance D prime then the
probability of rejection is some delta x
d prime right so this Delta here is
going to be the soundness parameter for
the tester and one of the nice things
about defining it this way is that these
quantities epsilon and Delta this should
be roughly of the same order of
magnitude what do I mean by that well
Delta has to be smaller than epsilon
this you get just by considering code
words at distance one right because the
probability of rejection is at more step
silent and you really like the attack to
be something like epsilon over 10 right
and if we can get that I'm going to
refer to such a tester as a strong test
all right
so any questions about this definition
all right so now as we know you know
just computing figuring out the right
rate distance trade-offs for linear
codes is an open problem and as you can
imagine when you add in this new
parameter which is locality then there's
even less known right so you know these
are a lot of parameters so for the
purpose of this talk I want us to focus
on two parameter regimes which are
particularly interesting one is the
asymptotic liquid regime where the rate
and distance ok so sorry the rate is K
over N the relative rate and the
relative distance which is d over n we
want both of these to be absolute
constants right and this is what is
called an asymptotic limit code now an
open question which goes back to the
work of goldreich and sudan from 10
years back is whether you can get
asymptotic lee good codes which are also
locally testable and they asked it for 3
query NTC's which is equivalent to
asking in our language whether you can
have asymptotically good codes where the
smoothness is order 1 over N and they're
locally testable the best we know to
date is this result of dinner which
basically gives us length n which is k
times poly log K so it is not a constant
times K it's slightly larger and the
relative distance is a constant now
another parameter regime which I
consider a very interesting but which is
probably not as well known is the case
where the distance is just a large
constant right so fix d to be some very
large constant like say a thousand and
now we ask the question as n goes to
infinity how many parity checks to be
made if you want the distance to be D
and the code to be locally testable so
here the smoothness parameter I'm
looking for is something like 1 over d
if these are constant this means I'm
allowing you to read something like n
over thousand coordinates so some small
linear fraction I want you to reject
things which are at distance D over for
from the code with good probability
right if I didn't have this constraint
this local testability constraint then
the best code is possible our PCH cords
which give you
n minus K is something like D over 2 log
n but these are not locally in testable
because of the absence of low rate dual
code words the best locally testable
codes we know come from this work of
Bhattacharya at all that there are
basically from reed-muller codes but a
very high degree and here the number of
parity checks is something like log n to
the log D right and I think a really
nice question here is whether you can
get bch like codes which are also
locally testable but the number of
parity checks is some constant depending
on d times log in you don't have this
factor of the in the exponent of the log
in right and we don't know the answer to
this ok so this is all I had to say
about locally testable codes and in this
talk I'm going to relate these to some
other objects which are basically kaylee
graphs on the boolean on f2 to ph right
so what is the Kelly graph on f2 to the
edge well the vertices are just all
points and f2 to the edge and the edges
are given by some subset s of elements
in f2 to the edge you have s1 through SN
and for each vertex X and element in the
set you have an edge between X and X
plus sign right just the standard
definition of kaylee graphs if you take
the set s to be e1 through eh you get
the standard boolean hypercube we are
going to be interested in the case where
the number of generators exceeds n so
obviously these are all sitting in an H
dimensional space they are not going to
be linearly independent anymore right
they're going to have linear relations
among them so a parameter of interest to
us is how independent are they i'm going
to say that this set s is device
independent if every subset of less than
D elements from the SEC is actually
linearly independent right again since
they're sitting in H dimensional space
you want to think of D as something like
say point 1 times H or something like
that right so I have n elements where n
is larger than H I am looking for every
sufficiently small subset of these
elements to be linearly independent
yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry yeah I have
it wrong you have more generators than
the dimension of the space so I want n
larger than H sorry for that confuse you
ok so what does this mean in graph
theory terms that any small subset is
linearly independent right so I want you
to think of it as some kind of analog of
a large girth condition so what do I
mean by this well this graph here just
because it's a graph on f2 to the edge
it's going to have a lot of short cycles
right because cycles in a que le goff
result when the sum of the edge labels
sums up 20 so for instance just take
anything like s1 s2 s1 s2 again you'll
get a cycle right but this cycle it
comes about from a trivial relation
among the SIS right and this kind of
cycles you anyway see in the boolean
hypercube now this has other cycles
which come about because of the linear
relations between the sis but these
kinds of cycles are long basically
because the SIS rdy is independent so if
you want a cycle that stems from a
non-trivial relation that will have
length at least d so what device
independence tells us about these crafts
is that if you look at the dealer to
neighborhood of any vertex it looks just
like the D over 2 dimensional boolean
hypercube sorry the Hamming ball in n
dimensional space of radius T over 2
because you don't see any cycles that
you wouldn't get in the Hamming cube but
yet the vertices are sitting in the
space of dimension age which is smaller
than so locally it looks like an N
dimensional hypercube but the vertices
are sitting in a smaller dimensional
space ok so these are the clearly graphs
that we are interested in and finally
what is in n 1 what is an l1 embedding
of a graph well it's just a mapping two
vertices in art the soul I shouldn't
call this D vertices in real space such
that the l1 distance approximates the
shortest path distance on the graph
right so each each mapping will give you
some distortion which is
approximation factor that you get and
the minimum distortion you can get over
all at overall l 1 overall such
embeddings were going to denote by c 1 g
it's the minute is the best
approximation you can have to the
shortest path metric using the l1
distance on points in RN okay so now
that we've defined locally testable code
scaly graphs and l1 embeddings i can
tell you what the main result is which
is that these following objects are
equivalent locally testable codes on one
hand and l1 embeddings of kaylee graphs
on the other hand here is a formal
statement of the theorem if you have an
nkd binary linear code with the local
tester that gives you smoothness epsilon
and soundness Delta that is equivalent
to a ceili graph on f 2 to the N minus K
right which has n generators which are
device independent and which embarrassed
into l1 with distortion which is epsilon
over Delta now remember in our testers
we said that we want the said that Delta
has to be less than epsilon and what we
want is that it's not too much smaller
it's something like epsilon over 10 so
that's the same thing as saying that
this embedding into l1 there is an
embedding into l1 which gives you
constant distortion right so once again
we're looking for Kelly graphs which
have more generators in the dimension
and generators in n minus K dimensional
space they are fairly independent their
device independent by D is the distance
of the code and they embed into l1 with
small distortion so when I say the
following are equivalent you can go from
a code to a ceili graph with a good
embedding and vice versa the second
condition only
the ratio but yes and it turns out that
that's the only thing that's important
you know yeah so actually I'm telling
you that give me something which gets
the ratio right I'll give you a good
tester there you care about the absolute
values but it turns out that if the
ratio is right then you can push the
absolute values and get them where you'd
like them so special given a kilogram
you can pick an epsilon and no there is
a right value of epsilon which is
roughly 1 over the distance and you can
get that provided the ratio is correct
right so yeah this is a good point but
you know it's sir it can be done
basically okay so we are not the first
to consider these Kelly Goff
constructions from our goals right a
nice paper of coat and a soft nod from
2006 they basically considered these
same kinds of kaylee graphs they didn't
stated in this language they spoke about
quotients of the hypercube but basically
what they observed is the following if
you start from a chord with large dual
distance you can construct a ceili graph
which is hard to embed into l1 so you
can think of our resort as building upon
this we are replacing this large tool
distance condition with saying that the
code is not locally testable which is a
much weaker condition in general and
then we're saying that this is a tight
characterization which means that if you
give me a Kayla graph that embeds into
l1 with constant distortion I can build
a locally testable code from it and
that's the non-trivial direction in this
theorem right so a couple of
implications now you know you can just
take all these open questions we had
about locally testable curves and reface
them in the language of Kayla graphs and
I think they lead to fairly interesting
formulations the question of whether
they exist asymptotic lee good strong
ATC's locally testable codes is
equivalent to asking if there exists
kaylee graphs on f2 to the h where the
number of generators is something like
1.1 times h super linear in h these are
something like point one hy is
independent and you want the resulting
graph to embed into l1 with constant
distortion and really this is the you
know this if you didn't have this
distortion condition than just taking
random generators of the Suffolk of
sufficiently large size would do the
trick for you like similarly this
question of whether they exist bch like
goals which are locally testable with
large distance in the kala graph world
it's asking the following question is
there a kelly graph on f2 to the edge
where the number of generators now is
huge it's exponential in H where the
base of the exponent is allowed to
depend on this distance D the set of
generators is dy is independent and it
has a constant distortion embedding into
l1 right ok so in the rest of the ten
minutes or so I'll give you a sketch of
this proof how do you go from a code to
a graph and vice versa this is easy the
more interesting part is how do you go
from a local tester to an l1 embedding
and vice versa and finally if time
permits you know then I'll be very
surprised and I'll show you some
applications all right ok so any
questions at this point yeah so do you
want me to just say again what it's
asking for you are asking for a ceili
graph on f2 to the H the number of
generators well does only two to the H
elements but you want it to be like 1.1
to the HR 1.000 want to the H you want
these generators to be dy is independent
for some large constant D that's the
best you can hope for with so many
generators and now you want this graph
to embed into l1 with constant
distortion right all right so
let's okay so first let me tell you how
to go from graphs to codes and vice
versa I'm sure I'm sure that a lot of
you see this already but I just tell you
we're starting with a graph where the
set of generators is device independent
how do you construct the code from it
well the code is just going think of the
parity check matrix being these elements
s 1 through SN right so your set of good
words is exactly the set of relations
non-trivial relations that these
generators satisfied we are just
considering all x's such that summation
X is I equals 0 right and you know you
can reverse this you start from a code
of distance D look at its parity check
matrix take those to be the generators
of your error-correcting of your kaylee
graph so at this point you know so this
is a pretty straightforward equivalence
in fact you know coding theorists will
tell you that this is really the right
way to think of an error-correcting code
its endpoints in a lower dimensional
space where any large subset is linearly
independent okay so now the question we
should ask is what we're trying to embed
the shortest path metric in this graph
into l1 what is the shortest path metric
mean for the cool right and the shortest
path metric here it corresponds to the
quotient and hamming metric on f 2 to
the N question did by see thank you so
if you're not seeing this before you
know i'm just going to define this it is
a very simple notion so what is Hamming
distance right you define this notion of
having wait for every element and then
you say the distance between X and Y is
the Hamming weight of X plus y so now
the elements of us the elements very
interested in our co sets of C so for
every cassette you define weight of that
cassette what is a cassette it's just a
collection of point so it is the shift
of the code define the weight of that
caused it to be the minimum weight
vector in back cassette and then
similarly you define the distance
between X&Y to be the weight of X plus y
okay so why is this something intuitive
from the coding theory point of view
well what are cassettes really you
should think of them as received words
which are grouped by error vector so
what do I mean by this let's say this is
our cool now when you get a code word
from the cool you don't really know that
it's error-free right you know that the
error is either zero or it's something
else in the code in the code because
there's no way you can tell the
difference between these things but you
make the very reasonable assumption that
if I get something in the court there
was no error right and so for all these
received words you are assuming that the
error is the zero vector you can think
of cassettes similarly when I get
something from this cassette you know
there's some ambiguity about what the
error vector is but then I look at the
minimum weight element in this cassette
which is sometimes called the coset
leader and I say that this is the error
vector so I was trying to transmit zero
this is what I got this automatically
matches up everything in the cassette
with a code book by the same error
vector and therefore this notion of
weight of a cassette is basically
capturing distance of this cassette from
the code which is the number of errors
that you got when you got something in
this closet right so it's a very natural
metric and when you do things like local
testing this is the metric that you care
about so I claim that the shortest path
metric in the graph is just the quotient
at Hamming metric so you know let me
just run through the proof but you know
it's a simple exercise it's easy to see
that each vertex in this graph is
actually a cassette of C corresponds to
a cassette of see here's how you make
this correspondence you have given a
vector X in 0 1 to the N where n is the
number of generators now start from zero
and take a walk according to this X what
that means is if X I is equals 1 you
cross the edge labeled by si go on doing
this where do you land up you land up
exclamation X I si if X I belongs to the
code then the sum is 0 so you're back to
where you started and otherwise you know
there's a whole cassette which will take
you to any vertex in the code and the
shortest part to get to a cassette
correspondent
exactly the minimum weight vector so and
if you didn't follow this you know it's
a very simple correspondence ok so now
finally we get down to business we have
this equivalence between codes and
kaylee graphs between the shortest path
distance on the Cayley graph and
distance from the code how the l1
embeddings correspond to local distance
these define l1 embeddings as a map into
real space but there is a well-known
alternate characterization called the
cut cone characterization which stems
really from the fact that you can assume
the map is sending you two points in the
hypercube appropriately rated right so
what is the cut corn characterization it
says think of your embedding as a
distribution on cuts in the graph right
it's a cut on the vertex space and now
there is some probability of separating
two vertices which I will call as
through XY it's the probability that a
cut sampled by this distribution
separates these two vertices think of
this as your approximation to the
distance between the vertices X and Y
and since this is a probability we are
going to have to allow our skills to
rescale graph distances but the
distortion is see if basically you can
rescale the distances such that the slow
XY is a see approximation to graph
distance ok so once you think of l1 as
this cut bone characterization it kind
of becomes clear that there should be a
connection to local testability because
after all what is a local tester it's
just a distribution on dual code words
and each dual code word naturally
defines a cut on the vertex set right
just by you take anything in F 2 to the
N colon see just take the inner product
of the dual code word you is going to be
either 0 or 1 and that defines a cut in
the vertex space so the suppose I've
given a tester for the code now what I'm
trying to do is to come up with an l1
embedding which is a distribution on
cuts and there's no surprises here I'm
just going to use the same distribution
that the tester specifies the claim is
that the distortion of this embedding is
exactly epsilon over Delta
so the proof is really simple and maybe
I should just do it quickly since we are
not completely out of time yet it
suffices to consider the pair X comma 0
the you know the origin and some vertex
X just by linearity the distance between
them you've seen is just the weight of
the cassette X so what is Rho X Y what
is Rho X comma 0 it's exactly the
rejection probability now on one hand
it's lower bounded by delta x the weight
of x just because this is how Delta is
defined it's the probability of
rejection is at least delta x the
distance from the goal but the
smoothness condition also tells me that
its upper bounded by epsilon times the
weight of x so why is this well without
loss of generality you can imagine that
this x you're thinking about is really
the coset leader which has weight which
is this since there's only an epsilon
chance that are going to read any of
these coordinates the Union bump gives
you this upper bond so therefore the
distortion is epsilon over delta the
more interesting direction is this
suppose someone gives you an l1
embedding right there's no talk of
locality here how are you going to get a
local tester out of it so what is an l1
embedding it's basically a distribution
on cuts or f 2 to the N quotient it out
by see the major problem is that these
cuts are not linear if their linear you
can really think of them as code words
in c / and you know for all practical
purposes you'd be done at that point so
when i say you're essentially done
there's still some subtleties here right
like because there's no talk of locality
at all why is this with some
distribution are linear functions why is
it going to be local why is it going to
be smooth why is it going to have
soundness but it turns out that those
things all work out the crux of the
matter is to just get a distribution was
that for me rock the crux of the matter
is really to get a distribution on
linear functions okay so this is how you
do it you safer for any distribution d I
can produce another distribution d prime
or linear functions which will give me
the same distortion so this distribution
is on functions or f2 to the
and quotient it out by see it's a
function on cassettes you can naturally
extend this to functions on the entire
bouillon cube right and okay the nice
thing about doing this is that now the
Fourier expansion is supported on dual
code words this is a standard fact from
Fourier analysis so now whenever the
distribution samples f what you're going
to do is to sample from the squared
fourier spectrum right so summation f at
alpha squared is one you can naturally
think of it as defining a distribution
on linear functions and you will sample
according to this distribution whenever
the other distribution samples from F
this will give you your distribution on
linear functions the claim is this can
only reduce your distortion and now this
embedding will define your local test so
this is a bit mysterious right why does
this work so since I'm out of time I'm
just going to give you a quick slide
with some intuition so there's a
well-known characterization of
distortion in terms of LP duality which
is that you can think of this as a game
between two players the first player
produces two distributions far and near
on pairs of vertices where far is
supported and vertices then a far apart
and near is basically on edges in the
graph the other player produces a cut in
the graph and his goal is to maximize
this ratio which is the probability that
you separate a faraway pair divided by
the probability that you separate a
nearby cave right since in a graph these
faraway pairs are much further apart you
would like to be able to produce a cut
which is much more likely to cut a
faraway pinner right so this is the game
and this kind of characterizes the
optimal distortion for a given graph and
you're trying to embed it into l1 now
the nice thing is that the graphs we are
dealing with are extremely symmetric
their vertex transitive they're really
nice graphs so you can simplify the
strategies of both players you can
assume that the first player produces
essentially a distribution on
displacements the first vertex is
uniformly at random and then the second
vertex in the fire distribution is
obtained by adding a large weight vector
to it
from some clever distribution in the
near distribution you're just adding an
e I and edge to it by some clever
distribution right and because this
player is only going to use strategies
like this it's okay for the cut clear to
use linear functions why is that well if
you think about distributions like this
and think about what is a boolean
function f going to do when presented
with the distribution like this you can
see that it's essentially like playing a
convex combination of linear functions
right so any strategy which you have
using a distribution on arbitrary
functions you can get the same pair of
using just a distribution on linear
functions okay I think I'm Way over time
now so I'm not going to say anything
about applications but once you have
this you can get a very simple proof of
this corner result which I mentioned
earlier you know I can't show you the
proof but it's short it may not be right
but it should but now you can
reinterpret all the results we have
about local testing in terms of l1 embed
ability in particular this earlier
result of benzoin Harsha and Ross
kournikova showing that small distance
is necessary for local testing is in
some sense analog is to the court now
result in the local testing void but
remember small dual distance is
necessary but it's not sufficient they
even sure that there are codes with
small dual distance which are not
locally testable this is particularly
interesting I think in the embedding
world because really dual distance
corresponds to spectral gap so you
should think of this result here as an
incarnation of the lineal London
rabinovich lower bound showing that
expanders don't embed into l1 these give
you graphs which don't have large
spectral gap but which are still hard to
embed into l1 and again let me just
mention that in this work we also give
an alternate spectral characterization
of LPC's where we say they are
equivalent to graphs whose eigenvalue
spectrum looks like the epsilon noisy
hypercube which gives a converse to an
earlier result with a large fraction of
this audience so let me just conclude by
saying that ok so what I showed you here
is a connection between certain costs of
course
and kaylee graphs there are lots of
connections like this already in the
literature like the connection between
epsilon bias sets and kaylee expanders
but usually these connections they
relate pseudo random objects these are
objects which we know they exist the
challenge is more about explicit
constructions now we are relating
objects which you know we are not to
ensure that these things I don't know if
the Yeti exists but you know I can
relate it to the existence of the
abominable snowman and the Bigfoot and
so on it's so forth yeah so you know
it's somehow gained us I don't know what
locally testable codes are but they're
the same thing as kaylee grass which
I'll good l1 embeddings I don't know
what those are right there but this
might be a useful way you could try to
use this to attack the problem of better
constructions or even just to prove
better lower bonds you know we've tried
both we haven't succeeded so far but my
hope is somebody else all right i'm
finally done do a distance us over
binary alphabet to them so when you so
you took a dual bch codes right these
are kind of generalizations of Hadamard
codes the code words tend to be nearly
unbiased you know they've paid very
close to one half and in a linear code
if you look at a few coordinates and
there's not a short dual code word
relating them you'll just see uniformly
random bits so sorry so maybe I should
just it's not that easy to find good
codes where the dual does not have short
code words and I definitely go
definitely sure this age does or small
off of it it's not easy to find good
codes where where the duel is also good
over smell out that the duel is also
anything good bch is not good in the SME
lawyer right it's not asymptotically go
ok i'm thinking of BS constants so in
this case it's dual code words are you
know they have extremely good distance
they are like distance close to one-half
which means that you can do yeah / GF 2
so that you can't possibly guess this
question sir
it was that creation again